네 오늘은 오픈 AI가 역대급 위기에 몰려있다
이제 이런 뉴스 때문에 증시가 휘청거리고 있는데
정말 좀 오픈 AI가 역대급 위기를 맞이하고 있는 건지
한번 좀 알아보도록 할 거고요
오늘 나스닥이 1.3% 정도 하락을 하고 있고
다우지수는 뭐 거의 똔똔
S&P500도 0.7% 하락을 하고 있습니다
기술주 위주의 하락이 있다라고 보시면 되고
그 중심에는 오픈 AI가 있습니다
이거 히트맵인데 이제 벨리 AI라고
월가제님이 하는 그 플랫폼에서 갖고 온 거예요
주로 하락한 회사들이 뭐 엔비디아라던가
브로드컴, 마이크론, AMD 뭐 이런 반도체 관련된 종목들이 주로 떨어졌다
혹은 이런 인프라 관련된 뭐 아리스타 네트워크 같은
뭐 이런 인프라 관련된 종목들이 오늘은 대부분 하락을 맞이했다
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다
그래서 어떤 뉴스가 있었느냐
바로 월스트리트 저널에서 기사를 냈는데
오픈 AI가 상장을 향한 고위험 질주를 하고 있는데
주요 매출이나 사용자 목표 관련돼서 지표가 안 좋았다
이런 뉴스가 있었어요
자 간단히 정리해 보면
오픈 AI의 CFO가 매출 성장세가 컴퓨팅 계약 비용을 감당할 만큼 빠르지 않다는 우려를
다른 임원들에게 표명을 했다라고 합니다
자 이게 무슨 말이냐
오픈 AI가 지금 컴퓨팅 계약
그러니까 뭐 데이터 센터가 지금 컴퓨팅 계약을 하고 있는데
데이터 센터 관련된 계약들을 이미 많이 해놨거든요
되게 큰 규모를 해놨는데
그 규모에 비해서 오픈 AI의 매출 성장세가 별로다라는 얘기를
CFO가 했다라는 거예요
그러니까 최고 재무책임자
그러니까 한마디로 이제 오픈 AI라는 회사의 총무를 담당하는
돈을 담당하는 사람이죠
이분이 이제 그런 얘기를 했고
그러다 보니까 이제 2, 3회에서 관련돼서 내부적인 갈등이 있다
아 이거 세물투먼 좀 잘못하고 있는 거 아니야?
너 컴퓨팅 확보에만 너무 매달린 거 아니냐?
라는 그런 내부적인 좀 이 사회 내에서의 갈등이 있다라는 얘기를 하고 있습니다
그리고 그리고 이렇다 보니까
이제 시장에서 CFO가 자기 회사에 대해서 좀 안 좋은 얘기를 한 거잖아요
그래서 야 이거 CFO랑 CEO랑 분열 아냐?
이런 얘기가 있으니까
이 CEO, CFO 세물투먼과 프라이어는 공동성명으로 분열서를 강력히 부인하긴 했어요
자 그럼 도대체 어떤 지표들이 잘못됐냐 라고 봤을 때는
첫 GPT가 주간 활성 사용자
그러니까 일주일에 한 번이라도 들어오는 사용자의 그 명수를
10억 명을 목표로 했고
그거를 작년 말까지 달성하겠다라고 했는데
그거를 실패한 게 아니냐 라는 거죠
왜냐면 공식적으로 이거를 달성했다라고
오픈 AI에서 발표를 안 했습니다
그러니까 보통 이제 잘하면 자랑을 하고 발표를 하잖아요
근데 그거를 발표하지 않았다라는 거 자체가
마일스톤 달성을 실패하지 않았느냐라는 생각을 하게 하는 거고
채찍PT가 연간 매출 목표가 있었는데
그거조차 미달한 거 같다
또한 구독자가 이탈하는 문제들이 생기고 있다라는 얘기가 있고
또 소비자 시장에서는 구글의 제미나이한테 밀리고
그다음에 코딩과 엔터프라이즈 시장에서는 엔트로픽한테 밀리면서
월간 매출 목표도 수차례 미달했다라는 얘기도 나오고
사실 월간 매출은 엔트로픽한테 따였다 이런 얘기도 나오죠
이렇게 내부적인 목표가 흔들리는데
CFO의 걱정은 뭐냐면
이미 오픈 AI가 6,000억 달러 규모
그러니까 한국 돈으로는 900조 원에 가까운
컴퓨팅 지출 약정을 해놨다라는 거죠
내가 데이터 센터에 900조 원 쓰기로 약속을
정말 수많은 회사들과 했거든요
이런 추세라면 정말 야심찬 매출을 달성하더라도
오픈 AI가 갖고 있는 돈은 다 소진될 가능성이 높습니다
특히 최근에 조달한 자금이 약 1,220억 달러인데
지금 대충 보셔도 아시겠지만
6,000억 달러 컴퓨팅 지출 약정을 했어요
6,000억 달러 쓰기로 했는데 모은 돈은 1,220억 달러밖에 없어
그러니까 이거 숫자가 대충 봐도 말이 안 되는 거잖아요
그래서 이거 너무 목표를 달성할 수 없는 거 아니냐
그리고 이렇게 미리 약속을 해놓은 것 때문에
문제가 생기는 거 아니냐라는 챌린지가 들어온 거죠
그래가지고 이제 이거에 대해서
오픈 AI가 이렇게 약속을 해놓은 것 때문에
월스트리트 저널 기사에 대해서 나름대로 답변을 했습니다
자 어떤 답변을 했냐면
이 원문보다는 좀 더 풀어서 쓴 표현들이 좀 더 좋은 것 같은데
일단은 CFO랑 CEO 사이는 균열이 없고
말도 안 되는 소리다
이 CFO가 1,220억 달러 최근에 펀딩 라운드
그러니까 최근에 투자 받는 라운드를 이끌었고
컴퓨팅에 더 돈을 받기 위해서 돈을 모은 거다
같은 방향이다 라는 얘기를 했고
그리고 오픈 AI 자꾸 너희들이 딴지를 걸지만
사업은 잘 못하고
사업은 잘 굴러가고 있는데
그 세 가지 증거를 얘기를 했습니다
첫 번째는 컨슈머
다시 말해서 이제 광고를 붙이기를 시작했는데
이 광고가 생각보다 잘 된다라는 얘기를 하고 있어요
그리고 엔터프라이즈 시장, 기업 시장에서는
원래는 마이크로소프트가 사실상 독점적인 계약을
오픈 AI랑 맺고 있어서
오픈 AI가 다른 회사들과 딜을 하는 게
엔터프라이즈 딜을 하는 것들도 그렇고
또 클라우드 관련된 딜을 하는 것도 그렇고
그런 게 좀 막혀 있었는데
이제 이게 완전히
풀렸다
그리고 최근에 이제 코덱스라고 해서
코딩을 잘하는 그런 AI 툴을 만들었는데
이게 이제 엄청 잘 된다라는 얘기를 했고
컴퓨팅 전략, 사람들이 이제 걱정하는 컴퓨팅 전략에 대해서는
결국 이게 맞았다
우리가 GPU랑 데이터 센터 공급을 다 선점해 버려가지고
이게 이제 AI가 본격적으로 폭발하면
컴퓨팅을 제일 많이 선점을 했기 때문에
6천억 달러, 900조 원의 계약은
리스크가 아니라 혜자다라는 얘기를 했습니다
그래서 저도 이제 이거에 대해서는
제 나름대로 좀 생각을 해 봤는데
이번에 이 오픈 AI 관련된 시장의 걱정은 좀 너무해 보인다
이런 생각이 일단 있습니다
왜냐면 오픈 AI가 갖고 있었던 목표 자체가 너무 높았어
사실 오픈 AI 주간 활성 사용자가
거의 1년 동안에 2배 이상 증가했습니다
4억 명에서 9억 명으로 사용자
활성 사용자가 2배가 넘게 증가했다는 거
특히나 이게 9억 막 이런 단위로 증가한다는 거 자체가 엄청나게
임이 크다라는 거죠
애초에 오픈 AI는 전교 0등을 목표로 했는데
전교 1등이나 2등을 한 게 아니냐
이렇게 봐야 된다라는 게 기본적인 저의 생각입니다
그래서 오픈 AI의 숫자들이 뭐
한 두 달 정도는 좀 부진한 것도 사실인데
전체적인 흐름을 봤을 때는
사실 뭐 그렇게 나쁘다 라고 저는 생각하지는 않습니다
다만 요즘에 워낙 엔트로픽이 날라다니다 보니까
상대적으로 조금 부진해 보이는 모습은 좀 있는 거 같고요
그리고 이 케펙스를 너무나 질렀다
얘기가 있는데
아 근데 또 제가 드는 생각이
요즘에 이런 여러 가지 AI 인프라 관련된 가격들이
이제 막 올라가고 있거든요
GPU 사용 가격이 계속 올라가고 있습니다
그러면 이렇게 사용 가격이 점점 올라갈 때
이런 AI 인프라들을 선점해 놓는 게
최대한 계약을 먼저 해놔서 선점하는 게
나쁘지 않을 수도 있겠다 라는 생각이 듭니다
오픈 AI가 얘기했듯이
미리 이 공급을 다 아예 잠가버린 이 형태가
저는 그렇게 나쁘지 않습니다
안 할 수 있겠다 라는 생각이 듭니다
그리고 또 제가 채찍 PT 5.5 최근에 나왔죠
써보고 있는데
5.4 보다는 확연하게 좋아졌다 라는 생각이 들기는 해요
그래서 채찍 PT 5.4에서 5.5 그렇게 나쁘지 않았습니다
계속 더 써보면서 저의 생각을 말씀드리겠지만
그렇게 나쁘지 않다
물론 여전히 저는 가장 먼저 클로드한테 물어볼 거 같긴 한데
하나를 고르라면 그래도 5.5도 채찍 PT 5.5 많이 좋아졌다
이런 얘기를 드리고 싶고
오픈 AI 테마가 진짜라고 한다면
저는 적어도 오픈 AI가 지금 기업 가치보다 높게 평가받을 가능성도 높고
AI 테마가 진짜인데 오픈 AI를 망하게 두지도 않을 거다
라는 생각을 좀 합니다
그래서 오픈 AI에 대한 걱정
제가 최근에도 만난 어떤 애널리스트 분들
혹은 또 AI에 관련돼서 좀 깊게 투자하고 있는 분들이
오픈 AI가 리스크다 이런 얘기를 많이 해요
왜냐하면 최근에 지표들이 조금 뒤처지긴 했거든요
그래서 리스크다라는 얘기를 많이들 하시는데
오히려 저는 이번에 5.5 나온 거나
또 최근에 대한 AI 이런 AI에 대한 열광
AI 광풍 이런 걸 보면서
오픈 AI에 대한 걱정조차 괜찮을 수 있겠다
오히려 그런 생각으로 조금 더 긍정적으로 바뀌고 있긴 해요
오픈 AI도 아직까지 심각하게 걱정할 정도는 아닌 거 같다
이런 생각을 합니다
다만 이제 시장에서는 오픈 AI에 관련주라고 할 수 있는 회사들이
많이 힘을 못 쓰고 있는데
대표적으로 코어이브 오픈 AI에 어떤 다양한 컴퓨팅 계약들을 약속한
그런 네오클라우드를
라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
또 오라클의 계약들도 대부분
오픈 AI의 계약이다라는 얘기가 많죠
오라클도 네오클라우드
그러니까 AI 데이터 센터 클라우드 사업을 하고 있는데
이 회사도 4% 하락을 하고 있습니다
그래서 이런 회사들
엔비디아도 당연히 오픈 AI랑 너무 긴밀하다 보니까
엔비디아 주가도 좋지가 않았고
이런 상황에서 또 이란과 미국의 갈등은
아름답게만 흘러가고 있지는 않습니다
트럼프가 이란의 호르무즈 해업 제안에 회의적이다라는 기사가
또 올라왔습니다
그래서 이란이 요즘의 분위기를 보면
이란이 오히려 고개를 살짝 숙이고 들어가는 느낌도 살짝 있어
미국이 지금 이란 앞바다를 점거하고 있다 보니까
이란은 호르무즈 해업을 개방하고
미국은 점거하고 있는 앞바다를 개방하고
일단 그 다음부터 우리가 조금 더 핵과 관련된 논의를 하자
이런 얘기를 이란이 제안을 했는데
이거에 대해서 회의적이다라고 얘기를 했습니다
어쨌든 트럼프는 조금 더 자신의 페이스대로
협상을 끌고 가고 싶은 듯한
느낌이 있고요
근데 이제 이란이 점점 급해질 것 같은
그런 느낌들이 드는 거는
이제 미국이 이제 거꾸로 이란 앞바다를 봉쇄하다 보니까
이란의 석유 저장소가 독날 위기에 처해졌습니다
이란의 저장 용량이 한 12일에서 22일 사이 정도 남았는데
결과적으로 이렇게 되면 이란은 석유를 저장할 수 없기 때문에
석유 생산량을 줄여야 되고
생산량을 줄이게 되면
이란 입장에서는
상당히 곤란해지고
또 아예 이란의 수출 자체를 또 못하기 때문에
이런 상황에서
역사상 최악의 위기를 겪고 있는
이란도 힘들어지고
또 사실은 또 이게 아시아한테도 안 좋을 수 있죠 당연히
그래서 이제 시장엔 별로 안 좋은 얘기들 뿐인데
어쨌든 간에 이란이 상당히 현재 상황이 급해져 있다
원유 생산의 중단을 피하기 위해서
폐탱크나 컨테이너까지도 동원한다라는
이런 얘기들도 월시저널 기사에 있습니다
그래서 요즘 분위기가 뭐 이래저래
이란도 어쨌든
수출길이 막히다 보니까 상당히 급해졌고
어떻게 보면 이거 자체는
이 미국과 이란 이슈가
점점 해결하는 방향으로 더 갈 수 있겠다
왜냐면 이란도 급해야
이 문제가 해결될 수가 있으니까
그래서 요런 거는 조금은 더 긍정적으로 보이는 부분도 있다라는
겉으로만 봤을 때는 부정적이지만
결과적으로는 또 서로가 똥줄이 타면 해결되는 방향으로 가니까
긍정적으로도 해석이 가능하다라고 생각을 또 하고요
이런 상황 속에서 또 한두 시간 전에 나온 기사인데
이란이
인정된 평화 계획을 또 준비를 하고 있다라고 합니다
뭐 디테일까지 다 얘기할 수는 없을 것 같고
어쨌든 이란과 미국이 계속 대화를 하기 위한 시도를 하고 있고
이란이 상당히 급해 보인다 정도로
이 뉘앙스를 이해를 하고 넘어가 보도록 하고요
또 그런 상황에서 아랍에미레이트가 오펙을 탈퇴했어요
자 오펙이라는 데가 뭐야
자 걸프의 국가들 사우디를 중심으로 해 가지고
우리가 이 석유와 석유 수출과 관련된 석유 가격을
원유 수출 원유 가격을 통제해가지고
통제해 보겠다라고 하는 어떤 기구거든요
집단이거든요
이게 이제 걸프 지역 국가들끼리도
분열을 하는 그런 분위기로 가고 있는 거죠
그리고 사우디 패권에 특히나 균열이 가고 있다라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다
자 그래서 아랍에미레이트가 오펙을 탈퇴하면서
오펙 내에서도 세 번째로 큰 생산국이거든요
자 그러면 사실은 사우디랑 사우디 친구들밖에 안 남는 거야
약간 좀 더 애매해지는 거죠
사우디가 원래 이제 오펙의 큰 영이고
그런 영향력이 좀 있는데
그래서 이제는 오펙이
원유 가격을 통제하는 기능을 더욱더 상실하게 되겠다
이런 생각이 듭니다
근데 이제 오펙이 그래도 지금까지는 항상
유가 변동성을 낮추는 그런 기구였거든요
그래서 유가가 너무 오르면 생산량을 좀 늘리고
유가가 너무 떨어지면 생산량을 좀 줄이면서
좀 가격을 컨트롤하기 위해서 좀 했었는데
이제 그런 기능들이 상실이 되면서
유가가 앞으로 더욱더 변동성이 커지겠구나
이런 생각이 좀 듭니다
그러다 보니까 불안함이 좀 증대가 되는 부분들이
있는 거 같아요
그래서 결과적으로는 안 좋은 뉴스들 많았고
AI 관련돼서 안 좋은 뉴스 많았는데
사실 AI 관련돼서 안 좋은 뉴스도
최근에 AI 관련된 장이 너무 좋았던 걸 감안하면
뭐 이 정도 하락 정도는 그냥 안고 가야 하는 거 아닌가
뭐 이런 생각도 들어서 모르겠습니다
너무 시장에 대해서 공격적일 필요도 없지만
또 너무 겁먹을 필요도 없지 않나
이런 생각을 하면서
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고
투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 고정 댓글 설명란 참고 부탁드립니다
감사합니다
자막 제공 배달의민족